la saga de la station spatiale
internationale se poursuit cette fois ci
les russes affirment qu'ils vont bientôt
cesser de collaborer avec les américains
dans l'espace et quittée en emportant
entre autres le module qui servent à
propulser la station je trouve ce soir
épisode
la position des russes et du sel à
suivre il y à peine dix jours moscou a
remercié dimitri rogozine le belliqueux
directeur de l'agencé spatiale russe qui
avait menacé en mars dernier de mettre
un terme à la collaboration spatiale
entre les deux pays le même jour le
kremlin signant un accord avec la nasa
pour permettre aux russes de continuer à
voler sur des fusées américaines et vice
versa une excellente nouvelle ospina la
modeuse
ce qu'est l'église seuil en achat de
famélique
mais la trêve entre les deux puissances
a été de courte durée à notre surprise à
pékin fraser 10 cas ne serait que dans
les femmes rashida
bée créer les russes disent qu'ils vont
se concentrer sur la construction de
leur propre station spatiale
si c'est le cas ils prêtent y avoir
bientôt pas mal de trafic dans la basse
atmosphère terrestre selon la nasa
plusieurs stations spatiales privés
seront appelés à remplacer la
vieillissante station internationale qui
sera détruite en 2030 et les chinois
viennent tout juste de grandir le
propres installations
de son côté le département d'état
américain a affirmé avoir été pris par
surprise par la décision de moscou de
mettre un terme à leur collaboration
vient d'une vingtaine d'années ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal